I owe my sister $20,000 that I would
like to pay her back she loow me his
money earlier in the year uh we invested
the money uh it it didn't pan out I was
uh calling for your opinion on getting
the loan how's your sister taking it
well she's been pretty patient with me
she's she's not harassing me at all when
were you supposed to pay her back we
were supposed to pay her within a couple
of months uh it's been almost a year and
it it's gone out it's gone just a little
bit longer than I would wanted to got it
okay
well you're but you're broke you're
broke and you're thinking now I got to
get this monkey off my back with my
sister so I'm going to go get a loan and
I'm then going to just pay the bank back
and I just think that's ridiculous I'd
rather you be spending all of your time
and effort just paying your sister back
you don't need to go to a bank or a
credit union or some private loone shark
type situation where they're going to
charge you enormous interest rates just
start paying her back